Amber Rose Isaac
was the love of my life
[Music]
I'm Tanya Lewis Lee and I'm Paula eiselt
and we are the directors and producers
of the documentary film Aftershock she
passed away due to an unscheduled
emergency C-section that stemmed from
medical negligence throughout her entire
pregnancy after shock tells the story of
the U.S maternal mortality crisis
through the lived experiences of the
family is most affected by this crisis
it's my daughter's birthday she would
have been 31 years old today so we
having a celebration on our behalf
shamani Makita Gibson we will never ever
forget you these families were able to
turn their grief into action in an act
of love for the women they lost love for
their community
and love for all of us really we need to
make sure that this doesn't happen to
anyone else
the first thing we both said was we
don't want to tell a doom and gloom
story we want to tell a story of
empowerment
the culture of birth in this country
itself is so backward we are the most
dangerous industrialization to give
birth in it was safer for our parents to
have children than it is for us today
why is that you need to be paying
attention if you're here in the United
States because as we've seen time and
time again what happens to the most
vulnerable ultimately comes for
everybody
black women are the Canary and the coal
mine if we fix it for black women we fix
it for everybody telling anari to how
mother passed away was
you know it's um
this is not a women's issue it's a
family issue it's a human rights issue
women who are part of families are dying
they're not statistics we have pictures
of shimani up everywhere
she's always around people would be like
oh you're following the fathers that's
interesting and we'd say of course
because they're the ones left behind us
together man we're not letting the pain
stop us this momentum it's like a wave
my dream with this film is that it will
be used as a tool for activists to help
be a catalyst for a cultural shift I
planned on spending a lifetime with
Amber I wanted to give her my life this
way I'm still going to
to come from America it's not going to
come from our politicians it's going to
come from the people in the streets
people like Mari Shawnee and Bruce are
out there doing the work
is it he hears you
we see
[Music]